Uuuuuuuuuuuuugh
I haven't played a game since I was born.
You haven't played a game until you've played, Dead or Alive 3 Extreme Fortune
AINSLEY
What is your favorite game?
Deadu araibu ekusuturimu de forutune
You're god damn right....
*coughs*
Deado o araibu ekusutorimu suri~!!
*laughs*
Dead or ali~!!
exue~!
Yes I know what you're thinking
Yes, they did ask me to be a voice actor in this game
Now I have the Japanese verison for some god damn reason (the second option says Owners Paradise pewds!)
I paid way too much-don't ask how much I paid for this...
It doesn't have English subtitiles, we're gonna have to play this...
in Japanese!
It's confusing as fucking hell, but like it's such a bizzare game to play
"Do you happen to know..." that it just makes it even better.
"About those glorious days?" Now I'm sure there is some sort of story to this game-
HO! {Pewds skipped the rest of the story, u might look up a playthrough if you want to know it}
Wait, she's 147 centimeters. She's a goddamn midget or a 12 year old.
What the fuck?
She fingering? She's fingering, what the-
WHAT IS THIS GAME? I haven't even started yet
HO!
Oh my god!
{our homegirl here likes to watch pro-wrestling and martial arts movies and is Japanese}
150 with those...She weighs 45 kilos, I think we know where most of the weight is, oh my god
I can't! This is too muc-is too much man!
Oh my god
How do I pick? there's so many good options*laughs*
If you ever feel like you wanna not live anymore, I really recommend just firing up this game and
See-see if it chang- you've change your mind afterwards
Here we go!
"It's the ocean! I'm really here!"
"I never-" BAHH "-thought I'd win a free trip from that raffle."
BLAHHH!
I have no idea what's happening but I love it!
I thought this was a volleyball game...I see two volleyballs but I don't see a court-
Oh my god.
"Um, if you'd like, why don't we play together?"
Am I supposed to answer that? *laughs*
WELL, I hope I don't offend her, uhhh
Let's go with this one (no)
"Maybe, next time...please"
I think I heard condom
I think we're about to p..play the game?
Let's play the pool!
How am I supposed to...
Can someone translate this? (laughing) What the...
Oh!
"I wonder if I can do ths...?
WHAT??
Is happening???
Was that a loading screen or was that the...
Day 1. Day 1 evening. Okay, so now we can...
So we can go to do different things, so we're on...
Okay, I get it! We're on holiday!
Let's go to Niki Beach.
"I wonder if I can do this..."
What is she... WHAT IS SHE DOING?!
I mean... KAWAII NE~!
Ooohhh.... Ho!
This is ridiculous.
Ainsley, this is ridiculous.
Stop, just... please.
Please? PLEASE?
"One day has already passed."
I'm gonna, I'm gonna... I'm gonna die.
I'm not gonna... I'm not gonna live anymore.
I don't understand. I don't understand how this is a game.
I am just looking at anime babes!
YOU LIKIN' THIS, YEAH?
Leave a like for anime!
Hey, uh... it's a pres- it's a present, everyone!
And now I will choose to decapitate her.
"I had a good dream last night! Good morning "
OHAYOU GOZIMAS!!!
Day 2, everybody! Clap it up! Day 2!
Day 2, everybod- wait, how do you play voleyball?! I swear to God...
That's a Volleyball!
Okay, let's do it.
Let's do it, let's just do it.
"Ahh... This feels absolutely wonderful."
She's not even lip-talking... whatever.
What is happening?
What is happening...
What IS this?
What was that?!
What was tha... it's a game!
With no gameplay!
{pretty much. why do you think there are so many boobs and everyone wears bikinis to sleep}
But it's still the greatest goddamn game!
How about we try one of these options? Okay...
She kinda lits up a little bit, doesn't she?
So you can play 2 players, I think.
Okay, so let's try...
Maybe now, ok...
X and Circle... ok.
Fruity? It says fruity.
I approve of the fruit!
This has been PewDiePie, everyone.
And I give my seal of approval!
Of the fru... fruity.
OH! MY! GOD!
What are they doing? Why they gotta... are they gonna... are they gonna...
(laughs)
"Ye~p, This seems to be difficult..."
I started too early! Where was she goin'?!
Oh my God.
This is... this is a game.
Okay, it IS a game, afterall.
Okay, so... let's try that again, then.
I love the atmosphere of the game.
Like it, it's got a good vibe.
It makes you feel good, it makes you feel warm.
Just like the sweet release of death.
(crying)
Help me.
Help me...
Help.
EEUUURGH!
Okay, here we go!
Go! Go! Run! Run! RUUUUN! COME ON! NO! GET IT!
FUCK YEAH!
"Don't mind if I do!"
Fuck... *failed weaboo language*
"I'm doing fine~!"
*more failed weaboo*
*rapping* "Can you hear me?"
Yes, I can hear you! (in response to song)
"One day has already passed."
WOOOW! What a rush!
WHAT A RUSH!!!
"Pardon my disturbing..."
*engrish imitation*
It's all about the love!
Friendship........... and anime titty!
(singing to the music)
Those bananas look delicious, amirite?
Wow, those...
"What a wonderful holiday, I had fun!"
Palm trees are so cool.
I'm not looking at anything, Marzia...
Well everyone, that has been... DEAD OR ALIVU!
I think we should play more, uh... I think we should play more.
I want to play more. I want this game injected in my blood stream.
If I ever... this is a public, legally binding statement.
If I ever get in a coma, I want this game to be playing 24/7.
And then I wanna stay on life support, and I never want you to wake me up.
Put this game in VR-
Is this game out on VR?
I think this game is out on VR! Oh my fucking God.
The game is out in VR.
It's been great, I'm just gonna fuck off for a...
This is all I've been doing as PewDiePie.
I'm officially quitting.
Uh, it's been..
It's been quite a journey with... we've been through quite a lot of things together.
And a lot of things just happen...
I just realized that all I really care about from now on...
Is to play...
Oooh! WHOAHO!
*otaku orgasm*
AH IT'S TOO MUCH!
TURN IT OFF!
I almost died.
I'm happy to be alive, everyone. I'm happy to be alive.
Alright, let's do one more vacation 'cause I...
Oh my God!
How old is she?
Like I...  It feels... Ok, nevermind.
Come on, we got to win this.
Come on girl, faster!
What are you doing?
Eh, eh, eh, eh, eh, eh, eh, eh, eh, eh, eh, eh!
God Damnit! BAKA NE!!
"Did you see that?"
Fuck you, fuck you, bitch.
You-dead-to-me. Dead. *spits*
You disgust me.
Alright, What else can we do?
I fucking love the music.
Let's go and have-
Let's go to the sports center.
Oh my god
We can buy a new- Hello.
Hello!
-Hello!
The customizations!
Aww, I don't have enough!
*suddenly british* For fuck's sake, man!
Alright, well I'm gonna play the game until we have it- no...
No! No! No!
You can buy...
A watermelone!
I just brought a watermelo~ne!
AND a PIZZA!
Yes, I wrapped the pizza! (laughs)
Did I just fu...
Did I just make a pizza into a wrapping gift?
That's amazing! Let's try... The Pool.
WHAAAAT?!
Okay, so we gotta hit the commands.
*lazily singing to the music*
Oh shit, this looks tricky...
Okay, here we go.
Oh my God this- NO! GET UP!
Oh, she's wet now! Oh no!
What? I only get one chance?!
"Heheh, I am the best!"
Shut the fook up...
This game just makes me happy.
I dunno what to s...
Shut the fuck up, alright?
You're spoken when spoke- you speak when spoken to.
"I'm back!"
Hey, by the way I have a gift for you.
It's a... it's a  pizza! (no pewds, she likes cream puffs)
It's a- *giggles*
I got you a-- WOULD YOU LIKE A PIZZA?!
I brought you a gift!
Oh, it's... what the fuck?
What the fuck is THIS?
I can play Blackj... oh, this game just gets better and better!
Are we in bikinis?
Okay, my bet.
Oh, nice. Classy.
Alright, we got 15.
Uh... I'll stay.
Uh-oh.
Heeey! We won!
It's kinda hard to play this game when you don't fucking know what the fuck you're doing.
Let's just go all in.
Alright, we're 5...
Uh, we're 5... uh, hit me.
12, hit me.
17, stay.
Come on.
"Oh, thank goodness!"
YUUGATA~!
Alright, I'm on a roll. I'm gonna fucking keep going!
OOOOHHH! OOOH I'M GONNA BUY A BIKINI!!!
Come on, come on.
Uh, Blackujacku.
Oh My God.
Oh my God! Alright, we stop.
Now we fuckin' stop.
No jokes.
Stop.
We can buy the bikini now!
We can buy the bikini.
EeeRRGHHH we can buUYYYYY the bikini!
(gasp) WE CAN GIFT HER THE PIZZA!
(crying)
I've always wanted to get my anime girlfriend a pizza!
Let's give her a pizza.
There you go!
I gave her... a pizza.
The greatest gift of love... a pizza!
This game understands human interactions.
I don't wanna play... I already played! I already played, alright?
Fuck you, game.
If I knew like, how to progress, that would...
Now the question is, if she liked the pizza...
Is she gonna give us something back? ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Okay, I wanna do the pool game again.
Because I fucking sucked at that.
I wanna do a 100 part series. This is my new Happy Wheels.
I'm doing 100 part series of this game, no joke.
Oh my God! Are we gonna bump butts? We're gonna...
I got a nosebleed.
Eh, uh bumpu~!
Take THIS!
BITCH!
Take this!
Asshole!
That's right my booty wins ev-
Ah! Fuck you!
Fuck you! Fuck you! Ugh! Fuck you!
Hell yeah! High five!
Okay...
Fuck you up! Fuck you up! Everytime!
HEHEHEHE~
Sports shop! Sports shop!
Let's buy... hello, hello, hello! Yes!
Yes! Yes! Yes!
Shut the fuck up, I have enough money.
I KNOW I have enough money...
I was on a fucking roll with that Blackjack!
I can't afford it? Are you kidding me?!
NONONONONO! Don't give the pizza box to her!
What are you doing?!
No! No, no...
You have not deserved the pizza box!
It drives me crazy.
You can't just end it out of nowhere!!
What the hell, I was playing... I was on day 3!!
I never got to day 3... god damnit!
Do not tell Marzia about this video.
But if you enjoyed, leave a thumbs up and uh...
Take away your AdBlock, YouTube doesn't like me anymore and...
Check out another video!!
They're probably gonna demonitize this one...
*weird screeching intensifies*